remember that totally disgusting white
supremacist rally in Charlottesville
Virginia some months ago where Trump
claimed that there were very fine people
on both sides including the side of
white supremacy one of the participants
in that rally was a US Marine corporal
I'm sorry lance corporal who has now
been kicked out of the Marines for
participating in the March after
spending a month in military jail I'm
talking about Vasily ospa stole Asst who
was convicted at a court-martial for
disobeying orders and making false
statements connected to that rally which
as you recall left Heather Heather hair
Heather hire not Heather hired dead he
wasn't arrested by police at the rally
but he ended up being court-martialed
after a report by Pro Publica and
frontline PBS showed that he was
involved with the autumn Waffen division
and the traditionalist Worker party
which are neo-fascist violent white
supremacist groups he wrote on August
12th quote today cracked three skulls
open with virtually no damage to myself
that was the day of that rally and there
are pictures from the event which show
him clubbing a counter protester with
what looks to be in this picture like a
wooden flagpole and the right-wing free
speech warriors are partially coming to
his defense not everybody but some are
coming to his defense saying listen this
is a First Amendment issue right this
was an individual expressing speech by
being at the rally the military is the
government so it's a violation of the
First Amendment for the military to kick
this guy out because they're effectively
suppressing his speech sadly for them
it's just not I mean first of all like I
said he was convicted for disobeying
orders and making false statements he
wasn't convicted or kicked out for his
views the military kicked him out
because he was convicted and sentenced
to a month in military prison and I'm
not a constitutional expert by any means
but I don't know your dad attacking
someone with a flagpole is covered by
the First Amendment is that that speech
that speech absolutely attacking someone
with a flagpole of speech and attacking
someone with a golf club is also speech
but
money to political campaigns that speech
- it's all speech so listen this has
nothing to do with his opinions about
race or anything else and and again he
wasn't even convicted of the violent
acts he was caught doing if he were
convicted of beating someone with a
flagpole that also wouldn't be First
Amendment repression if the military
said we need him out so I think that the
military did the right thing if you're
curious double jeopardy doesn't apply to
the military and civilian courts so you
could be tried in the military and then
in civilian court for the same thing in
this case if he was tried in civilian
court it would more likely be for the
beating of a counter protester with a
wooden flagpole and this is the right
decision by the military
this shouldn't be controversial you
can't have people like this representing
the country if you're a fellow marine
you shouldn't want this guy serving with
you whether it's in your platoon or even
in your office or in the mess hall
wherever it is that you're working this
guy's a systemic danger and could get
you killed if you serve with a guy like
this yeah this is the is is there any
strong argument that this isn't
obviously the right decision does this
guy have any chance at getting a job it
looks like he got dishonorably
discharged from the military or at least
that looks like where it's heading and
then he also has white supremacists on
his resume sure oh that doesn't look
good to prospective employers I was
thinking like is this going to be an
awakening that sets him on a more
productive path where he will turn his
life around and educate himself about
racial oh my kid Who am I kidding
obviously he's not going to do that and
he'll probably end up diving headfirst
into white supremacy and end up in even
more trouble although we have
interviewed on the program two three or
four people who have been very deep with
violent white supremacist groups and
they did get out of it you know it is
possible and I hope that he does I'm
just saying statistically it's not the
most likely maybe in five years we'll
have him on the program for an interview
saved by reason what was the Joshua
Turner who has that organization saved
by reason who was able to turn it around
which is a good thing I wish him the
best and I hope that he's able to do
that